you're Midwestern
kids are we going in
there Jesus
[Music]
who never make the mistake of thinking
it's over cuz there's always one more
surprise yes yes yes I'll probably go
watch that I'm so excited for it I saw
the trailer I'm going to go through the
house right now now it's going to be
very scary I think I think so yeah that
that wasn't a very convincing that was
like I think so I'll be listening to it
if it gets scared yeah that's very fair
you're going to hear it more than you're
going to see it I was supposed to see it
with my friends before the May so that
it like made more sense cinematically
but we're going to see it after so we'll
see it still what is it about demonic
possession that's
scary I mean Los ask that losing control
in my opinion you can't you have no
control over your body that seems pretty
damn scary to me I mean it is fun when
you're a kid and you can say bad words
though I mean it's supernatural but also
kind of realistic barely gets me no way
nuh-uh not because you don't want to see
it just because I don't think I could
make it all the way through it without
yeah I'm see I'm I'm with you but I'm
I'm not as smart as you and it's going
to scare the crap out of both of
[Music]
us the ex this is my favorite horror
movie and I've never done a horror Maze
Before why do people do this oh my in
the
blood no it's possession the devil got
inside
her ah jeez holy
crap oh my God it never
end W Jesus
[Music]
Bravo
Satan and that one like pants La looking
dude had it in like he was particularly
mad at me I don't know if I said
something negative about a movie he made
but he was not
[Music]
happy for me personally no oh wow oh
no is that the one with the girl
in the backyard I don't think she made
her the backyard she's pretty much in
the bed the whole
movie it's definitely up there I think
as a kid it scared me more than it did
as an adult Love The Exorcist as one of
the greatest horror films ever made it
is it is absolutely up there but it's
not the scariest what in your opinion is
the scariest movie ever I'm going say
The Shining I personally got really
freaked out with hereditary ooh that's a
good one scream scream scream yeah The
Conjuring
my guy was like nah it ain't Scream It's
a Conjuring I think I would say The
Conjuring that's just a classic for
me for me Halloween I was going to say
polter guys that was pretty scary for me
when I was younger it was Child's Play
but now it's Paranormal Activity The
Marked Ones wow okay The Marked Ones I
think that was one of them right there
the honestly the movie us scared the sh
I am terrified of the reality of the
black
phone I love the black phone I would say
Nightmare on Elm Street not only the
finger glove but also the fact that
everyone needs sleep no matter who you
are everyone has to sleep eventually so
the scariest part of that is he's always
going to find you you're making me
scared of this movie all
over now I don't want to go to sleep
again and I love taking naps I'm 43
years old sleep is all I have left in
the
world let's go to Hawkins see how these
kids are
doing who jeez the very exist what done
one minute one minute
no
oh
woo there's like a lot of this and it
cuz there was stuff coming at me from up
top so when you're in Hawkins you can
never just trust Straight Ahead got to
look up got to look back got to have
eyes behind you that's all for this
episode of on the street thanks for
joining us for Halloween Horror Nights
comment right now and let us know what's
the scariest movie for you and when does
your Halloween officially start I'm Mark
Ellis I'll see you next time I got a
score to settle thanks for checking this
FD out head over to rotten tomatoes.com
for everything in the world of movies TV
and in between a lot of rejection to
this
job you're at Halloween
harits that's all right folks